I Leonard that made the game-winner  Anthony Briggs in advance CJ will take  it on the baseline  by hollis-jefferson CJ holding sweeps in  low to the floor outside terminal  like Carmelo Anthony drills it straight  away from 16 feet out 3 and 3 10 seconds  remaining in this baby and the Blazers  take a lead at 2 this year could be two  places turn but Melo was just planted  the whole time available as an outlet if  CJ needed it the CJ doesn't force the  issue he doesn't feel like he has the  clear look and you see the defender up  top with Damian he's stuck with him he's  not letting game open right here so that  just gives Melo even more of a drive in  Lane 2 half